it's kind of like a family affair today
Brockman yeah I know right yeah we had a
whole bunch we had we had the the
Griffin brothers right right in our
number one Shaquille and Shekinah
Griffin they've got a new book and now
the studio is filled with Hamptons right
but the Hampton family is surrounding
them our studio right there mom dad's I
don't want to sit in my chair and you
know a whole host of Hamptons as RJ
Hampton New Zealand breakers point guard
is here on the Rich Eisen show good to
see you sir no gets the you got it walk
us through who's here in studio with you
today
um Soph my beautiful mom that I seated
right there my little brother Ryan in
the back yeah yeah I'm like grandma
Helene and I got my daddy so you sit in
the seats that we have behind the couch
that we have behind that's right there
that's that's great and I think we may
have a de facto member of the family
calling in shortly on the program his
name is uh what's his name again
the Sanders that one Dianna I think he's
gonna be calling it in the middle of the
segment at some point so it means we
would have Dionne and Stephen a Smith on
the same show which is why not it's
great for us but good to see you here
arguing and obviously a lot of folks
talking about your decision yes as a
five-star recruit that you could pretty
much certainly with your board scores
that you put up choose pretty much any
institution of higher learning to choose
go and play basketball for the United
States
you chose the New Zealand Breakers of
the Australian the International
Basketball League why did you do that I
just felt like at this point in my
growing and development the basketball
player I felt like I was ready for the
next level and to take my my talents to
professionally so you would take it
instead of taking your talents to South
Beach like LeBron Bron we had to help
him a beach I mean it's that's that's
all the way around the planet yeah you
know pretty much yeah you decided to go
there why why the Australian basketball
league they just laid it out for me they
they they really want me to succeed they
want me to be a great basketball player
a great professional so I thought that
League
the best and the competition is really
good I know many people know that but
it's really a great League yeah I know I
think the time zone difference makes it
a little bit difficult to follow what
the exploits of that league but the idea
of oneand dunning at a college campus
here playing on ESPN espn2 fs1 you know
ABC CBS that didn't appeal to you not
really because I feel like my mangos be
in the NBA and when you're in the NBA
playing on national TV all the time so I
feel like I just want to be the best
prepared basketball player to come in
and make an impact my first year my work
year and then be a do you understand why
people are a little bit scratching their
heads over your decision probably cuz
I'd applied and I didn't have to do it I
didn't hack it I went to college so I'm
a lot of people that I've taken taking
this route had to do it because maybe
the test scores or other issues but
probably because I didn't have to do and
I could have went to any college okay so
are you planning on going into the NBA
next year yeah that's the plan to play
this season and then into the draft next
into the draft next year yes sir because
you signed a two-year deal it's a
two-year or one year one in one year
okay with them with New Zealand is it
the New Zealand Breakers yes okay hmm
so let me ask you this gorgeou Hampton
here on the Rich Eisen show so you're
gonna essentially your plan is to
one-and-done what a woman done kind of
in that league I haven't seen anywhere
how much you're getting paid I mean I
don't really know all that I feel like
it's a good amount okay so you do know
how much you're getting paid yeah okay I
mean certainly if you know the Hampton
family and knows Deion Sanders as well
you know I'm saying that that business
has been handled can you tell me how
much you're getting I don't know if I
could tell you but it is it's it's I'm
happy with what I'm getting bit you're
happy I'm happy
okay the over/under on commas is one and
a half do I take the over or the under
on that I always say you're really close
your heart okay all right
I'm prying uh I understand you don't
want to say yeah but I guess the idea of
an education is that something that
you're gonna pursue as well at some
point
oh yeah sure my mom's not gonna let me
not get my college degree so I just felt
like you only get like one shot at being
the best possible player in the world
that you can be and I make it into the
NBA and getting that shot and you can
always go back to college you can always
get your degree at any any point be 80
years old and get your degree okay
oh why not so you need to you you can't
go into the NBA now for people who'll be
hearing you right now you just can't go
from one to the other I just I can't go
from high school to the NBA they don't
allow it you have to be 19 years old too
and I'm only 18 okay only 18 yeah going
to New Zealand are you is your family
and any of your members your family
going yeah my mom my dad and my little
brother everybody's going to New Zealand
brockman they're right behind you do you
want to I mean out you need to stay here
don't be a plus one right there I'm an
honorary Hampton I feel it all right so
the whole family's going yeah they're
all going well that's got to be cool for
now yes it's good have you ever been
ever been I haven't been in New Zealand
not even once
not one you don't even know nope I've
been in New Zealand or Australia so how
did you choose the New Zealand Breakers
uh it just was the factor of its the
zeros right is it did they pay you the
most I think is the the way I was gonna
fit in with that team there's a lot of
other teams that were good but I felt
like with the players they have around
me and what they said they were gonna do
with me to make me the best basketball
player I felt like that was the best
team okay what's your game like for
those who may not know your game they
didn't see you play prep in in Dallas in
Texas probably just a fast-paced point
guard one of the taller point guards
that that's in the country and and just
can give my teammates a vault but they
can't score if I have to and and just a
two-way player like to play defense so
you're where we're watching you hoist
some threes right here right now who did
you model your game after oh I think
this year I really kind of modeled my
game after kind of like Steph Curry not
was just shooting threes but just the
way he he moves without the ball and the
way he just just carries himself on the
core again
teammates open just by him being the him
being one of the best players on the
team okay so you I mean you're six five
right yes you didn't think about going
to Michigan that didn't cross your mind
the University of Montana that went that
graduated my best friend committed to
Michigan who's Jalen Wilson then he D
committed when a coach Tom P line what
yeah he's one of the University Kansas
Bill Self just sliding in there like
Juwan Howard some sort of jamoke it off
the street itself never played in a
final four never played never even wear
baggy shorts and played star movement
ever Chris Webber right I'm sorry I
don't mean act like you're nuts in here
all of a sudden but that just pisses me
off
Bill Self come on Oh a favor okay so do
you know who else is on your team RJ I'm
just wondering like when do you go when
do you actually go I leave on I think
anywhere from August 10th August 15 so
I'll be there like less than a month
okay what are you gonna do between now
and then just go back home train get
ready and just work on my game just
stronger so when I get over there I'll
be ready okay are is it true did lamella
ball come into the is he's an early to
some means or is Lavar coming do we know
if he's going down I mean he's got just
a song all right dad's got a step rod
how many you versus levar on the court
who wins that one rod who takes that one
down we gotta get get Deon on the phone
will you have his number there Chris
right you've got Dion's number get get
him on the phone right there I need to
we need to figure that thing out so okay
so you're going down in New Zealand and
then you're planning on at some point do
you contact NBA teams are you allowed to
contact NBA teams I mean how do you make
your your plan work I feel like RJ just
like my agency they're gonna do a great
job of just having NBA teams come over
watch me while I'm over there and plus
I'll be back the season ends the regular
season ends February 14 so I'll be back
probably
early March way early for pre-draft
process okay yeah and then you play a
couple games in here the state my first
two games actually against the Thunder
and the Grizzlies so you could be Dean
up Russell Westbrook your Russell
Westbrook for sure okay first what
happens when that happens do you think
you don't have to see me ever have to
see you okay do you learn that from Deon
that sort of talk I mean I know what you
pick up from Dino
Oh what I pick it I feel like he's just
his own person like he doesn't let
anyone tell him who he who he is or he
can't be okay that's basically the main
thing is the caller there Chris problem
Dion Dion exits are on the rising show
what's up prime humbleness Oh humbleness
I am your humble host right I got I've
got RG Hampton to my regular my jacuzzi
tub watching this I sorta sing
appreciate that
mental note I appreciate that yeah
shredded I'm shredded I'm looking good
real good right now you know I'm
sneaking up on 52 and I'm uh I'm gonna
take my shirt off from a 50-second okay
well let me taste about this kid this
kid is all of that in a bag of chips
what I mean by that no smoking no
drinking not doing anything absurd he's
not gonna get in trouble you're not
going to hear about him going to jail
anything crazy in the streets he's a
great character kid now let me tell you
about his father oh that is my boy I
love them that was my right-hand man for
years we travel the country with me I
love he and his wonderful wife and the
kids to the life this isn't the balls
this this is a whole other level of
parenting and basketball is it RJ has
been brilliant for this since his
infancy he's been pushed
he's been guided he's been unbelievably
mature word for this moment
so I mean I love this family I really do
well I did we give rod a stick Mike Mike
LTS alright
you're on the air with prime what's up
big fella tell me who's well now man you
know you know I feel about you man once
we started hanging and I really got to
be honest with you man
you know you taught me not only how to
be a good man but you taught me the the
the the rigors of father ship on the
road I mean we long day to day for years
man but you never let me sway away from
my family and you just you just
instilled that in me man and like I said
the true part about it I never told RJ
who you were who do do totally Dion was
but I never told him in primetime was
and when he found that he was mad at is
that true or Dion was growing up by my
time growing up I didn't know I just
thought he was uncle Braun
I just thought he I was always around
rich I was not that guy he just saw some
old guy hanging around I was kind of
wondering oh that's all he still earns
dead money from the Cincinnati Reds to
pay what I love about their decision is
they flip the script man they flat out
flips the script on the NCAA and I
absolutely love it you talk about the
NCAA institution and using kids across
new kids in our Manipal way two years
making profits off for them what do they
make of Zion last year is it ridiculous
so now you got a educated family we're
not gonna let you make money off us if
there's money to be made we're gonna
keep it in-house and we're gonna mature
him get him prepared for the next level
and we're gonna go overseas as a family
family and I love it man they flip the
script I absolutely love it how much did
he play a role in all this do you think
RJ um I mean just watching like when I
fight when I finally found out really
who he was and just like like watching
like I would go on YouTube and just
watch like like videos and and
highlights and documentaries like he
just like he did his own when he did at
the prom Tom Wayne he never let he never
did at the Atlanta Falcons way or the
the Dallas Cowboys way or any type of
what he did it his way so that's kind of
like the world he played in this
and the Braves and the Cincinnati Reds I
take it off the back seat of that
motorcycle take you places you don't man
prime you are a superb baseball player
of note as well I was just trying to let
RJ understand that in case you don't get
those YouTube videos yeah of course you
did man one thing that this kids
understands and one thing his dad is
always understood of hard work and I'm
putting my money on rod against uh the
mr. ball rod will use them
rod and I have had some legendary
four-on-four contests we always wonder
Jim Jim we've won the Jim all over Texas
so I'm putting my money on rod against
the barb oh I got it I got Ross I talked
him out of this game somebody give all
let's get that going rock for charity
you know for charity like that's our
ball out of his game that is legendary
we can make he's gonna try to Bank rod
down that's all he gonna do but I got
his bat out that game by the way
bitrate range game RJ I am in love Dion
you can't see that's your little brother
just having a good time being on camera
over there prime you take care enjoy
that bubble bath or whatever you're
doing right that's prime right there
there you go
uncle Dion you just YouTube that oh my
god he's only one of the greatest
athletes of all time and now coaches as
well Deion Sanders hey RJ don't be
stranger I know timezones gonna be crazy
but we let ring you up just to hear how
you're doing down there for sure okay
sure thanks for coming in your family
yeah and rod it's great to see you again
it's been a minute as they would say and
thank you so much for being here the
whole Hampton family on RJ Hampton 14 on
both Twitter and Instagram good luck
with the New Zealand breakers thank you
thank you so break in the mold as you
are clearly Siller that's RJ Hampton
from
the Rich Eisen show tuned to audience
channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app